like we owe it to our viewers to pause
for a moment you know this is shocking
and appalling and I honestly don't even
know what to say about it
Today Show anchor Savannah Guthrie and
Hoda Kotb reacting to a shocking new
allegation brought against their former
coworker Matt Lauer that he allegedly
raped the woman whose sexual misconduct
complaint against him partially led to
his firing from NBC News in November
2017 we don't know all the facts in all
of this but there are not allegations of
an affair there are allegations of a
crime and I think that's shocking to all
of us here who sat with Matt for many
many years so I think we're going to
just sort of continue to process this
part of this horrific story Hoda and
Savannah say they prayed together before
addressing viewers on Wednesday morning
I think I speak for all of us we're
disturbed in our core yeah and we have a
commitment to keep you in for us and we
will continue to do that
Hoda and Savannah's on-air message came
just hours after Variety dropped this
article featuring a new interview with
Brooke nevels a former NBC employee
whose name had been kept secret until
now
she claims Lauer anally raped her while
working together at the Sochi Olympics
Lauer has since released this letter to
et the three-page statement is the first
time he's spoken out publicly in a major
way since his firing Lauer defends
himself in the lengthy letter claiming
his relations with nevels were
consensual it was all part of an affair
he says quote I have never assaulted
anyone or forced anyone to have sex
period Lauer goes on to claim that any
woman saying their relationships were
non-consensual is just looking to
exploit the circumstances of the
situation for her own gain and calls
this whole ordeal extremely damaging to
his family quote it is alleged that an
extramarital but consensual sexual
encounter I have previously admitted
having was in fact an assault it is
categorically false ignores the facts
and defies common sense Nevel shares
more of her story for the first time in
Ronin Pharaohs new book catching
kill lies spies in a conspiracy to
protect predators it's his first-hand
account of how he says NBC News tried to
shut down his investigation into Harvey
Weinstein which led to the launch of the
me2 movement and ultimately Lauer's
demise at NBC now NBC News has denied
Ronan's version of events and et has
reached out to Ronan Farrow for a
response to Lauer's letter for that
update and more to come with this story
stick with ET I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]